Interaction is a well-trodden question within
the EDH community with raging debates over how
much is too much, how little is too little, what
types are the best, and what types are the rudest.
I’ve thrown my hat in this ring before, but what
has struck me recently is how many people seem
to not really understand interaction as a
concept, and what it is accomplishing for
any given deck. As with many subjects, we as
the EDH community have created lots of little
myths about interaction and removal. When I say
myths, I don’t mean strictly untrue statements,
but rather kinda true things accepted as
undeniable fact, or sometimes-true things
overgeneralized to always be true. So, I wanna
tackle some of these misunderstandings, and in
the process drill into the fundamentals of what
interaction does, why, and how best to use it.
To start with, let’s talk about what’s
worth considering alongside your removal
when deckbuilding. I’ve occasionally gotten some
flak because I tend to have a pretty wide scope
of what I consider interaction and removal, and
I’ll sometimes organize my interaction suites in
ways that other people find unintuitive.
Graveyard exiling is a form of removal,
bounce spells are a form of removal, and defensive
cards like propaganda are a form of removal,
though the degree this label will fit can
depend on the deck. I think the reason this
rubs people wrong is because they have a very
specific idea of what removal entails—removal
is when you remove an opposing thing, and
more specific tools like defensive cards,
graveyard hate, protection, and pinpoint land
destruction deserve to be placed in an entirely
different mental category, their own boxes on
a checklist. In some decks these things will
warrant this sort of separation, but in many
others doing this is a waste of time at best,
and in the worst cases actively counterproductive
to constructing a functional deck. No,
instead of this sort of checklist approach,
the best way to think about interaction is
as a network of overlapping solutions
to a number of specific gamestates.
Let’s say an opponent plays Animate Dead to bring
back an Archon of Cruelty, and let’s say this
poses a problem to us—how can we shut this down
before they start attacking us with it? Well,
we could destroy the Archon of Cruelty
with creature removal, we could destroy the
Animate Dead with enchantment removal, we could
counter the Animate Dead with a counterspell,
and we could use instant speed graveyard hate to
exile the Archon of Cruelty in response. There are
some less common approaches as well, but let’s
stick with these four. In this case, all four
of these options would be ways of removing this
threat, dealing with this gamestate that I’ve
decided is problematic to us. I’ll allow myself a
single cheeky comment here and point out that, for
our purposes here, Abrade is not a removal spell,
and Cremate is. For another example, let’s say our
opponent is playing a Krenko deck, and is starting
to pop off. Several goblins, a couple sources of
untapping, an Anger in the graveyard, the works. A
piece of instant speed creature removal could deal
with this, so long as the Krenko isn’t wearing
a Swiftfoot Boots or something. However, there
are also a number of less absolute ways to slow
down or survive this sort of play—you could have
a Soul Sister out to allow your life total to keep
pace with the number of goblins on board, or you
could have a defensive card like a Ghostly Prison
already in play to limit the number of attackers.
You could even have a Thalia, Heretic Cathar to
have the goblins enter tapped, or have a Rakdos
Charm at the ready to explode your opponent’s
life total as punishment for their token crimes.
Now what point am I trying to make here,
you might ask? Put simply, in EDH problems
are often more complicated than one single
problem permanent that needs to be removed,
and even more complicated than just being the
occasional spooky board that needs wiping.
Single target removal and generic board wipes
can be the solution to a lot of problems, and
I’d certainly never tell you to avoid these cards,
but they’re far from the only options available,
and a lot of times they won’t be the most
efficient way to tackle a given problem. Sources
of graveyard exile are generally extremely cheap
per mana, as are stax cards, defensive permanents,
and other things that stick around to hinder
multiple opposing plays. As a result, it’s
beneficial to get to know these types of cards,
and the sorts of decks and metagames where they
could play the role of more traditional removal
better. When newer players are being inducted into
the ways of the commander format, discussions of
interaction tend to center card types as a thing
to focus on—you want a way to hit creatures,
to hit artifacts, to hit enchantments, and so
on. To be clear, I have no problem with this—card
types are undoubtedly a good thing to think about
as a starting point. However, as you get more
acquainted with common play patterns of decks,
and which ones you tend to have a problem with,
it becomes much more useful to focus on situations
that need to be remedied. Some decks won’t care
about certain types of threats as much—a go-wide
tokens deck isn’t going to be as spooky if you’re
playing a thick-boarded midrange deck, a pinging
engine isn’t going to be as spooky if you’re
playing a deck with a good amount of lifegain,
decks with more explosive plays aren’t going to
be as spooky if you’re already packing a handful
of hate pieces, and so on. If you’re playing
a deck with a focus on some defensive cards,
you’re already going to be somewhat shielded from
a lot of plays that involve large combat steps,
and if you’re playing a deck that runs
some counterspells for protection,
you’re already going to have some ways to nail
critical centerpiece cards or combos. Likewise,
an interaction suite that does a good job
handling the threats of one table might not
do as good a job at a different table—you need
to know the environment you’re stepping into.
To clarify, if what I’m saying sounds
overwhelming, you shouldn’t worry about it
too much. What I’m describing is what takes place
during a potentially months-long process of tuning
and pruning a deck, not necessarily what you
should be doing when you’re first putting together
a deck. It’s fine if you’re using templates or
rough rules of thumb to start out with, but as
you get deeper into tuning an individual deck,
and as you get more experienced as a deckbuilder,
it’s generally good to move away from deciding
counts of different cards using a simple template.
There’s no way to know exactly how many removal
spells or overall interaction spells you need
because different forms of removal will have
overlap in the profile of what they can answer,
and different interaction spells will have
different degrees in how much they hinder opposing
plays. Some of my decks run interaction counts in
the teens, but others might include 20-something
or even 30-something cards that interact
with the resources of opponents in some way,
excluding life total. And, excluding life total
isn’t even necessarily a fair thing to do. I don’t
know if you’ve ever watched how a person with 14
life conducts themself within a commander game,
but it’s generally very different than how
somebody with 34 life conducts themself.
That 14 life total person will often find themself
holding back on attacks and chump-blocking more
often than they’d like, and they’re also often
going to be more conservative in the sorts of
spells they play. Tapping out to draw a bunch of
cards or play some powerful amplifier permanent
is perfectly commonplace for somebody at
a higher life total, but it’s a terrifying
proposition when finding just a little bit of
extra damage could let an opponent swing lethal.
For that reason, having a higher degree of
life total pressure can often allow for a
bit smaller of a removal count. All sorts of
late game permanents that would generally be
good candidates for removal become a lot less
of a concern if their controller is in range of
being rapidly focused down. This is one reason
why Magister Sphinx is such a useful card in my
Sharuum Slide deck—the deck generally looks to
build toward a late-game win, so having a way to
put an opponent on death’s door if they’re pushing
out of control a bit too early is a sweet escape
valve that takes a little bit of pressure off the
deck’s suite of control spells. Overall, though,
this life total rule is going to be most pertinent
in aggro decks, and especially in Voltron decks,
which typically look to knock players down one
at a time with commander damage. Careful threat
assessment and a few swings with a big commander
can be worth countless pieces of removal,
and for the pieces of removal that do exist
in a deck, it can be beneficial to have them
be targeted more toward the stages of the game
that are worth worrying about. Get rid of some
blockers, kill something that can let an opponent
stabilize, remove a bigger mana dork that might
let your opponent contest you. Flame Slash isn’t
going to be a great card in most slower decks
because it misses a whole lot of stuff you’ll
see in the later stages of a commander game,
but that’s not super important if your most
important turns are going to be happening earlier.
Ultimately, all I’m trying to say here is
that different decks will utilize removal
for very different purposes. If you’re
playing a creature-based aggressive deck,
you might want to focus on options that can
clear out blockers, and you likely won’t want
much in the way of conventional board wipes unless
you have ways to make them one-sided. If you’re
playing a combo deck, you’ll want to focus your
interaction on dealing with obstacles to your
combo, and spending removal on only the most
imminent of threats. In either of these cases,
your interaction will exist predominantly
to buy yourself time, and things opponents
have that require time on their end like a
draw or mana engine might not be a concern
to you at all. By contrast, if you’re playing
a slower, more controlling deck, you’ll want
to focus more of your removal on knocking out
resource generation such as card draw engines,
since not letting opponents get ahead of you
will be important in winning in the long game.
You also might want to focus on interaction that
targets multiple things or which accomplishes
multiple tasks, since those tend to be more
card-efficient. These cards do tend to cost
more mana, though, which brings me to the final
little myth I want to tackle. Let’s talk about the
interaction staples of the format, specifically
when they should be played—or not played.
Typically, the forms of removal considered
“staples” are ones that cost very little
mana and hit a limited range of targets, such as
Nature’s Claim, or which cost a bit more mana but
which hit a variety of different targets, such as
Generous Gift. There are also a handful of board
wipes that also end up heavily played because
they’re just hands-down the best thing available
in the color. Now, am I about to explain to you
why these cards are garbage that you need to rip
out of your deck? No. In fact, I’m about to tell
you exactly why these cards are generally so good,
because I think a lot of people have a tendency to
accept that these cards are always the best option
and treat it as dogma, a primordial and unshakable
feature of our world alongside gravity and the
rising of the sun, and this does this cards a bit
of a disservice. Let’s start with the flexible
removal spells—why are Beast Within, Chaos Warp,
and Generous Gift good cards? Right off the bat,
let’s make something clear—one of these cards I’m
a lot less likely to play than the other two. Can
you guess which one? If you said Generous Gift,
you’re correct, and that’s not an insult to the
card itself. It’s functionally identical to Beast
Within, after all, unless your opponent is playing
an Elephant deck. No, it’s merely a statement
that Beast Within and Chaos Warp are exceptional
cards—they are hard removal in colors that really
don’t have much hard removal for creatures,
and in the case of Chaos Warp, in a color that
lacks enchantment removal on top of that. There
are several two color combinations in which
these will be some of the only removal for
certain permanent types you’ll get, and that’s to
say nothing of our monocolored compatriots. So,
you won’t catch me wasting my breath trying to get
people to take these out of their decks. However,
there are also color combinations where you’ll
have access to lots of other options—Beast Within
won’t feel as essential in a green-black
deck since you’re going to have a number
of other reliable ways to remove creatures, and
as I alluded to earlier, any deck that includes
white is going to have ways to deal with a
variety of permanent types already available.
So, does that mean that these cards aren’t worth
playing in color combinations where they’re not in
some wholly unique niche? Not necessarily. For
one, these hit lands, though the importance of
that fact can vary a lot depending on the power
level and matchup you find yourself in. Secondly,
if your interaction suite is relatively narrow,
somewhere in the ballpark of 8-12 cards,
there will be a lot of utility in having each of
those cards be as flexible as possible. If I’m
packing 9 pieces of interaction, after my first
seven draws of the game plus my opening hand, I’ve
on average seen about one and a quarter of these.
If I’m running 14 pieces of interaction, I’ve seen
around 2 instead, and if I’m running 18 pieces of
interaction that number is more than 2 and a half.
If I have a diverse interaction suite and I’m
seeing multiple pieces of interaction pretty early
into a game, there’s a good chance I’ll have a way
to deal with a specific problem unfolding in front
of me, but if that average is lower, running more
of these versatile staples will likely be a good
idea. Personally I prefer to run a higher count of
interaction that’s more carefully integrated into
what my deck is doing, but there will be times
when it makes sense to run a lower count—some
decks can threaten player kills or wins faster,
in which case removal won’t be as necessary, and
other decks will be tight on deck space and might
struggle to integrate removal into what they’re
doing. Regardless, versatility of removal is going
to be one of the deckbuilding knobs that you can
modulate, and it’s good to have an understanding
of when it’s more important and when it’s less.
Now let’s get to the cheapest removal out there,
your 0, 1, and 2 mana options. These are powerful
for a very simple reason—they’re just mana
efficient. If you’re exiling a 4 or 5 mana
creature with a Swords to Plowshares, that’s
going to be a significant tempo advantage. This
will be most relevant in a fast, proactive deck,
one that is mostly dialed in on its own gameplan
and just needs little bits of removal that it
can fit in around the edges of turns in order
to prevent opponents from causing problems. The
most extreme cases of this are in cEDH—here,
almost all instant-speed interaction is going
to be 0-1 mana, and you’ll sometimes see 1
mana bounce spells played because it’s just
that worthwhile to temporarily deal with any
nonland permanent for 1 mana. Even if you’re
not playing some insane combo deck trying to
pop off on turn 4, low cost removal options
can still feel quite good if you’re willing
to play a lot of card draw. Because that’s the
downside of these—they’re single target removal,
and some of the most popular options actively
give your opponent a thing, so by default you’re
going to be falling behind the table in cards.
If you’re happy to go ham on card draw in order
to counteract this fact, that’s fine enough,
but going for removal that can hit more targets
or which provides some other benefit can really
help a deck to keep up in cards and run smoothly,
especially if there’s a lot of elements to
fit into a deck that will be taxing your
deck space. If you want a stronger sense of how to
densify a removal suite like this, I’d recommend
watching my removal video from 11 months ago,
because that was a large part of that video.
I said earlier that 0-2 mana removal is strong
due to its mana efficiency, and for some use
cases that’s actually kind of an understatement.
Specifically, any time a deck is holding up mana
to use interaction at instant speed, there is
effectively a mana cost associated with that,
since if the interaction wasn’t needed the mana
goes unspent. This is one reason why cheap,
instant-speed kill spells are popular, and it’s
also why low-cost counterspells are especially
highly prioritized in EDH. And that’s good and
fine—a deck with mostly sorcery speed plays will
want its counterspells as cheaply-costed
as possible—but as with low-cost removal,
the issue comes when players treat this preference
as unshakeable dogma. 3 mana counterspells aren’t
inherently bad, nor are 4 mana counterspells or
5 mana counterspells—what matters is whether you
have other things to do with that mana you hold
up. The simplest version of this is in something
like a draw-go style control deck. My friend
Hans has a Lilah, Undefeated Slickshot deck
that follows a simple premise—there’s 20 blue red
instants that draw cards and/or remove things,
and once Lilah is on the board the deck
just plays very reactively, mostly only
casting plotted spells on its own turn, a thing
that doesn’t require mana. This allows it to
play a suite of exclusively high-mana-cost
counterspells, which can have backbreaking
upsides compared to their low-cost counterparts.
Aethersnatch fully yoinks an opposing spell,
Sublime Epiphany does a whole bunch of stuff,
and ending the turn with Time Stop in response
to a critical main phase spell or ability
can be equal parts hilarious and devastating.
You might argue that this is niche advice, since
most decks aren’t going to be playing at instant
speed, but it’s nonetheless good to keep in mind
as an option. The other way to have higher-costed
options make sense is by having unspent mana
rollover between turns in some way. Storage
lands or a Kruphix-adjacent commander might
come to mind here, but the most well-supported
option for this is treasures—you can spend
treasures on counterspells if they’re needed,
and if they aren't needed the treasures get to
stick around. Finally, there are also a smaller
number of counterspells with some built-in
modality. I’m a big fan of Mystic Confluence,
and Cryptic Command and Thassa’s Intervention are
other cards that also feel fine enough played for
their other modes. This is also why Three Steps
Ahead has broken the three mana counterspell
mold and actually seen decent levels of
play—it can be a three mana counterspell,
but if it’s not needed it can also be a three
mana filtering spell, and it can also soak up
extra mana with decently mana-efficient results.
There aren’t a ton of amazing modal counterspells
at the moment, but this is definitely an
area that I’d keep an eye on, and if we
see more options like this printed I could see
EDH shifting toward higher-costed counterspells.
As a final note, counterspells are one of the
rare types of card that will consistently embody
multiple roles in decks—they’re a form of removal
in a sense since they can nail pivotal spells from
opponents, and they’re useful for protection
since they can counter opposing interaction.
When I’m deckbuilding, how I categorize them will
depend a lot on how important protection is for
my gameplan. If I expect to have critical plays my
opponents will be trying to answer, I’ll generally
either put counterspells in their own category,
or lump them into a protection category along
with other sorts of protection cards. Sometimes
I’ll even throw recursion spells into a protection
category as well if there are critical permanents
to protect, which can help with conceptualizing
a deck so long as you can keep in mind that
different cards are accomplishing the protection
task in different ways. On the other hand, if I
have less to protect and I expect my counterspells
to be mostly aimed at stopping my opponents’
plays, putting them in their own category is less
helpful for understanding my deck, and I’m more
likely to lump them in with the other interaction
in a deck. And, that’s what this is about—how
you categorize your cards matters for being able
to understand your own deck and make sure you’re
able to accomplish the different tasks you want to
accomplish. My Sharuum Slide deck does use its
seven counterspells for protection sometimes,
but I keep these cards in the broader control
category because these cards are a bit too messy
in what they accomplish to put into a standalone
category. Three of them are counterspells with
cycling that can be used as fuel for Astral Slide,
one also serves as a flickerable removal engine,
one of them has transmute, and how am I even
supposed to categorize what Nimble Obstructionist
does? In this case, the interaction suite of this
deck is too convoluted and multifaceted to be
worth trying to make more digestible, and I know
any overhaul of it is going to require a whole
lot of effort anyway. The one aspect of my control
suite I do differentiate with a subcategory is the
creatures with ETBs since building flicker-based
engines to suppress opponents is a key part of the
deck, and if I click the category in Archidekt
to select those cards this becomes evident.
I have other decks I could go into detail
discussing the interaction suites of and
how I categorize them, but that would pretty
well destroy the pacing of this video. However,
in preparation for MagicCon Vegas I’m
doing audits of a bunch of my decks,
and so I’m releasing a bonus segment of how the
interaction suites of each of my decks are looking
and what changes I’m looking to make before
Vegas. Some of these decks I haven’t visited
a whole lot lately, so it’s kinda fun evaluating
the decisions of my past self. To access that,
you can either join my Patreon or my newly
launched YouTube membership—this video will
be both places. With that said, thanks for
watching, and here’s a preview of that video.